i know that i'm not the best sister wife
i'm not close that close to mary i'm not
that close to robin i'm super close to
janelle i mean i get jealous
so it's really hard
to have a relationship with sister wives
that are in a good marriage it's really
difficult
you don't get to blame me alone for how
this relationship has gone for us
blaming you alone yes you are you're
telling me i'm never around and that i i
was i was not here before kovid how many
days have you spent with us like four
days before covered
like full days full days
so let's just say we've lived here for
800 days
he went hiking with us
once
he's been kayaking with us twice one
time he didn't even get in the water
that's
three times he's gone with us
three
out of eight hundred
i was here for full days regularly i
remember full days here
but when people work they leave the
house when people have things to do they
leave the house i don't have time to
play like she has time to play
i got a lot of work to do and a lot of
responsibilities i don't get this you
don't show up here and stuff like that
it's like what are you doing all day
it's certainly not cooking and cleaning
because then i
listen there's nothing to say here why
are you insisting on holding on to me
i'm why
whoa this isn't working cody you said it
wasn't working too
you said you were not i think it's not
working in me
you were interested in a sexual marriage
with me you said that you said people
survived for years without having an
intimate marriage you said that you're
blaming me
for me being turned off by your behavior
we've married for 25 years i've known
you for almost 30 years
don't insult me
tell me straight up if you don't want to
be married to me anymore you don't want
to have an intimate marriage with me
anymore flip and tell me it is cowardly
man
come on
[Music]